the liberal push for Equity is making
our kids Dumber Portland schools are
workshopping new quote Equitable grading
practices the plan would prevent
teachers from assigning zeros to
students who cheat or fail to turn in
assignments and yep you guessed it's all
being done in the name of racial Equity
according to the school's handout quote
do not issue zeros provide a minimum
grade greater than or equal to 50
percent for work that does not meet
expectations is incomplete or is missing
we've reached out to the school district
for comment but we haven't heard back
yet now Jessica all of this stuff in
Equitable grading takes away from real
life where you know these kids they need
to balance if they get a job or if they
have a sports after school and what this
does is it doesn't prepare them for the
future at all oh I'm very against this
it's just workshopped at this point I
hope that they don't go for it there was
something else that they were going to
try in the Oregon school system which
ended up getting scrapped a couple years
ago with the previous governor I think
that these are dangerous experiments
that are going to end up putting us even
further behind where we have to go and I
I would say again that I have not met
real live people that are supportive of
these kinds of people I might be one of
them I I I I not for not highlighting
the upper tier and those that are
prospering and studying and thriving and
doing very well they should be rewarded
for that but I think there's a huge
problem that needs to be addressed right
now if you look at these state report
cards we are just passing kids through
the system I mean they're graduating
kids that are you know seniors in high
school that have a first grade reading
level I mean so what do you do you give
them a zero and then what happens next
so part of this experiment needs to be
to send them off somewhere else right
some into a different room have a
special
um you know class format for bringing
these kids through but giving them a
zero and passing through the system is
almost worse right I mean what are we
doing about these kids so that they're
not falling completely behind and being
left behind that's not good for society
either and you know part of the problem
is that you take away the rush the
benefit that kids get when they Excel
when they do well when they get an A
when they achieve we take that from them
it's almost so we take away their
ambition no one has ever mistaken me for
a legal scholar yes but I am calling for
a full Federal takeover of the Portland
City you need the National Guard in
there you furlough every bureaucrat in
that City and you clean house their
workshopping child abuse judge you're
going to get kids in 10th Grade that
don't know how to read and everyone's
going to go okay that's fine if you do
this here's the deal if you start doing
this that means every kid you graduate
must work in Portland okay make all of
these idiots that you've produced work
for the city and see how that goes
because the parents aren't going to
agree with this the students aren't
going to agree with this no one thinks
this is a good idea except Jessica and
her ilk I literally said I think this is
a bad idea
all right Brett oh my okay but I want a
dress shirt I want to address this
because this is the second time I want
to ask you a question all right forget
it let me play your game what's your
question all right don't play my game
answer the question this is the second
time that you say I hope some something
doesn't happen you know something
doesn't happen this is your party right
right it's kind of a weird party to be
in when you worry they don't succeed
well it's not my whole party aren't
there things that Republicans no but
this these are things that this whole
idea of racial disparity comes from your
party and Equitable grading is in fact
racist because you're Dr you're
addressing these people as a group
rather than individuals that is part of
your party racial disparity is
light on both our both are parties
because I know you're going to say who
freed the slaves I know Abraham Lincoln
was a republican so it goes back to that
and then moving through that well it's
an important point of this but you can
acknowledge that there are systemic
challenges facing poor kids in this
country black and brown kids in this
country and not thinking about a
solution okay so then so you're right
there this is what's important the fact
is you don't need to separate these kids
into groups in order to help racial
disparities so I just but the racial
disparities is done by this is my point
if you look at kids as individuals this
problem Falls away you stop treating
them as groups that's the racist part of
this but this Equitable grading system
it mentioned nothing about race in that
oh it's uh according to this it says
Equitable grading grading it doesn't say
only
no it says it's to address racial
disparities and inequities right
generally which can just be being poor
that's the same I think you're I think
I've crushed you Jessica
is up next
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else